you has with the aggressive move yeah
the rookie has the confidence to attack
just like Kelsey Plum does that was a
beautiful layup from Collier
[Applause]
Plum the jumper except the dribble a lot
of contact as she drove the Baseline
Plum it's two points off of the turnover
that's the shot that uhas needed to see
go in
Plum gets free on the Baseline the shot
is blocked Stokes couldn't get it off
Plum space wanted a reckless closeout
call on Kayana trailer Becky Hammond not
happy at all on that one behind the back
pass from Gray on one ankle to Plum for
the three a nine to nothing run by the
aces they've opened up to 60.
young
finds a cutting Plum she wants to see it
every game so you always know who the
blink's best player is it's nafisa
Collier
one with 16 in the first half gets two
more right there
[Music]
[Applause]
tried to hand it off to Stokes Plum
comes up with it Kelsey Plum does not
miss from there to Plum four on the shot
clock Kelsey Plum makes her move gets
free and hits the shot Wilson kicks it
out to Stokes in the starting lineup
tonight for Parker and now a baseline
three for Kelsey plum
team now for Collier if he's the Collier
figured out a way how to score here in
the second half Kelsey nipped trying one
more time Kelsey Klum also go through
everyone before I get it right had her
Under Armor dog camp
[Music]
Plum oh she's just adding to that career
high
having fun tonight Kelsey plum